Middle Earth shadow of war is finally
here and if you want to rise to the top
of models food chain but aren't sure
where to start them we're here to help
the early game can be a bit overwhelming
particularly if you didn't play shadow
of Mordor you don't get the absolute
GameChanger that is the dominate ability
until quite a few hours in so this guide
will focus on helping you out in the
games early hours before you can make
Oryx do your bidding
put these handy tips into practice and
you'll be decapitating orcs and mounting
karagöz with the best of them in no time
[Music]
it's going to take every ounce of your
strength to make more than a dent in
this or log number one quick and easy
skill points killing grunts in shadow of
war sadly doesn't net you any XP towards
leveling up of course taking on captains
and war Chiefs or the vendetta and
nemesis missions and of course main and
side quests will get you a skill point
upon a completion there are quicker ways
to get them early on in the early game
the easiest way to get a quick skill
point is to purify all three hide ear
towers in each region doing so also
unlocks a fast travel point so it's
super useful to do after purifying a
tower use it to identify all the
collectables in the region collecting
the filled in symbols Shelob memories
and gun durian artifacts in each area
next a skill point so don't ignore the
collectables in the early game with
tally ins elven agility it really
shouldn't take you long to run around
and grab them all plus you get great
bonus abilities and items for collecting
the lot the shadows of the past side
missions also offer a skill point if you
complete the mission within a certain
time limit or do a bonus objective
they're basically like playing the game
with cheat codes on so they're really
not that taxing but so worth it for that
easy skill point number two the best
skills to invest in early on when you
open up the skills menu there's a lot of
options to choose from and you obviously
want to choose wisely after unlocking
each base skill you can unlock three
upgrades for it be aware that only one
upgrade can be active at a time so have
a read of the options before you invest
some of the more useful ones I unlocked
early on where elven lights which
lines nearby enemies and it's upgrade
cleansing blaze which sets them all on
fire super handy for crowd control I
store minutes upgrade shower of ice
freezes all orcs in front of you perfect
counter and it's upgrade rain of arrows
allows you to refill one elf shot with a
perfectly timed counter now in the early
game you really don't have that many elf
shots so each one is precious and this
upgrade stops you from coming up short
detonate can help you make mischief from
afar as you can unleash a fiery
explosion or call in a group of spiders
or ghouls to swarm nearby enemies with
its upgrades poison tendril poisons a
grog barrel from a distance to damage
any orc the drinks from it and of course
the shadow strike allows you to reach
faraway enemies in a flash and move
around the battlefield with ease mounted
skills are also definitely worth
investing in as soon as you can
not only as some captain's afraid of
Kara Gore's they can take on a few
enemies on your behalf also there a
nifty way of getting from A to B number
3 upgrade your weapons enemy captains
and nemec's drop items upon defeat with
epic and legendary captain's dropping
back salute
there are various armor sets you can
collect and wear like the bright Lord
set you obtain by unlocking all the
elven doors each piece of epic and rare
gear has an Associated challenge
complete the challenge and pay a tiny
amount Mirian to upgrade your gear it
doesn't give you a whole lot more damage
and you can only upgrade an epic or rare
piece once but you can get some awesome
buffs like a certain percentage to
chance that an enemy's head will explode
and freak out others these challenges
can be as easy as getting 5 head shots
or killing 3 beasts so it's an easy way
to get some really cool buffs now when
it comes to the legendary gear Kella
bramble can upgrade it multiple times
until it hits max level however The
Associated challenges are definitely
geared towards the mid to late game so
you can take advantage of them right
away but what you can do in the early
game is collect a bunch of them and
upgrade them later than before don't
forget the gems
killing captain's pulling down monuments
and basically causing chaos in morale
can bag you a gem and if used properly
can net you some awesome bonuses each
piece of gear now has a gem slot that
you need to unlock by paying a thousand
marryin now this seems like a lot in the
early game but it's worth doing as early
as you can because the bonuses you get
from gems are worth it also you don't
really need marryin until act 2 when you
start doing fortress assaults and by
then you should have banked plenty of it
from completing missions and
deconstructing old gear in the gem menu
you get a preview of what bonuses you'll
get if you hover over the gem and you'll
notice that the gem offers different
bonuses depending on what you attach it
to this can range from better loot drops
bonus xp or even a level boost for your
followers so read this and adapt
according to what you want if you've
picked up three of the same type of gem
you can combine them together to create
a more powerful one that yields better
rewards when attached to gear it's also
worth noting that if you attach gems to
your stuff removing them later doesn't
destroy them so you can swap them in and
out at will
I'm a5 use your environment the easiest
way to take on captain's early on is to
use the environmental hazards to thin
the crowds shoot the hanging meat to
bring in karagöz burst the ghoul egg hit
more guy fly nests poison grog explode
fire pits and free the core cooped-up
creatures do as much as you can to cause
chaos in the outpost and try to isolate
the captain from his followers you can
it'll make your life a whole lot easier
than just getting completely overwhelmed
by his lackeys the enemy AI is actually
pretty forgiving if you need to run away
and recoup for a little bit orcs have a
relatively short attention span to climb
somewhere high where they can't see you
wait for them to stop looking for you
and dive right back in the captains and
WarChiefs don't really tend to leave
their area so you can whittle their
health down bit by bit if you really
need
so there we are some quick and easy tips
to get you started in shadow of war for
more on the game including late-game
tips and a guide to get the most out of
the Nemesis system make sure to keep
your eyes peeled to GameSpot
[Music]